this is rice paddy country and I'm here
to get my hands on Venom's most
important ingredients and to learn the
wrong choice of rice dishes maybe these
people one thing you've got to do first
off it's cooked they're right perfectly
today the village are celebrating the
end of the rice harvest with a feast
Sowers the only person in the village
who speaks a bit of English that was
amazing
honestly I felt like Steve McQueen now
and I'm a little bit late okay and the
harvest is finished come any time for
the feasts right yes those little
beauties there this northern hill tribe
not only picked the rice they process it
too but there are no mod cons here
what's going on there
it's fascinating they kept the grace
period they take all the little rice
grains off the plant and then it's all
swept into the middle of the concrete
this is incredible
yeah mommy that by this long in my life
yeah
I'm sweating like a Vietnamese Pig is
what all the ladies doing the morning
some cameramen sometimes the risottos a
complete different way now
what still boy laughing hey big boy your
turn next
in this forty degrees heat I think I'd
better stop before I keel over
time to put all this rice to good use
and learn what they do with it and what
is this in making its most may write
rice and it's maker isn't working
and so it's pounded rice yes mixed with
water yes nice thick you know what is
amazing for me is the fact that we cook
rice one or two different ways in
England you guys completely different
meaning on rice and she puts onions and
pork in the middle part and the madam
commotion thank you for me to make these
paper-thin rice cakes hunger the need to
apply a delicate touch yeah I'm fine the
chest part sorry
how embarrassing hopefully I can impress
him with my culinary skills I've lost
half my mix chef here we go one more
time there's a fine art to this and I
just don't have it
come to me can we come in coming I'm not
gonna screw up anymore John
I'm in danger of busting his chair
started delicious very good I'll buy
some new stools